au chapitre des faits divers à présent
un violent incendie a détruit une partie
de l'école primaire rabelais richelieu
d'amboise hier soir plusieurs salles de
classe sont inutilisables pour la
rentrée de lundi luca chopin était sur
place
il est un peu plus de 20h30 quand les
pompiers d'amboise sont dépêchés à
l'école rabelais richelieu actuellement
en travaux
des riverains ils y ont vu des flammes
deux salles de classe sont ravagés
rapidement l'incendié maîtrisé mais la
configuration du bâtiment ralenti le
travail des pompiers
c'est long lorsqu'après la phase
d'extinction qui a été finalement la
plus rapide
il y à toute la façade des garnissages
puisque les matériaux utilisés
faisait que le feu continue à se
propager à l'intérieur des cloisons
trois jours avant la rentrée l'urgence
est maintenant de pouvoir accueillir les
enfants dès lundi les bâtiments sont
condamnés maintenant notre mobilisation
va être des landes pour lundi matin que
les enfants puissent être accueillis
dans un lieu sécurisé en plus la période
du confinement et l'accueil des enfants
est important tous ceux qui vont pouvoir
aller travailler
donc effectivement dès demain matin nous
nous mobiliserons les huit classes de
l'école devraient être relogés dans un
bâtiment voisin le temps de mener une
enquête et de réhabiliter
l'établissement